thank you I have a three-year-old
granddaughter and she's been diagnosed
with sensory processing disorder and she
doesn't talk much
or she can't really say words hardly and
she doesn't like loud noise okay now
when was she diagnosed with us at birth
her at three know at three and she don't
look good in half okay so she has sort
of been the normal range of things and
walking and talking and so she was four
years old yes everything until she's
almost three okay now what about any
skin pump does she have any eczema
dermatitis arrives any rough skin dry
skin on the back for arms or legs no
okay what about asthma bronchitis No
okay any diarrhea or bowel problems
constipation diarrhea paint is any
brothers and sisters no okay she's the
only child so far yes okay what is she
way you think 40 40 pounds okay 40
pounds uh-huh okay one other question
I'm assuming that the mother is your
daughter yes okay and so does your
daughter have any problems does she have
any asthma as a kid or skin pom-poms
right no okay all right Charmaine are
you there I'm here I'm here okay what
would you do for this child three years
old has sensory problems meaning she
can't hear maybe visions not perfect
smell and taste you know it could be
things going on with the brain with all
these sensory things okay and so whether
it's pressure about chemical and stuff
we don't know the answer to that maybe
it's maybe it's a absorption problem we
don't know that so what would you do for
their child waves of 40 pounds well I
would get around a gluten-free diet just
for the heck of it
yep just in case you need plus get
around the health or healthy brain and
heart pack based on her body weight and
and I would also add the synaptic to it
okay how many eggs would you give her uh
at her age probably - maybe yeah - you
had to twice a day very good yeah so
char's exactly right the healthy brain
and hard pack and you know she's you
know by the time you get in everything
she could weigh 50 pounds so she's you
know close to 50 pounds so that when the
healthy brain heart attacks in the last
two months it's one for one hundred
pounds of body weight per month so she
gets a half a dose of everything a day
and I would cut it in half so you're
giving a quarter of a dose twice a day
which equals out to a half of those a
day but each of the things in the box we
call the healthy brain and heart pack
and then the synaptic let the nerve
cells talk to each other one tablet a
break it in half
grind it up and some applesauce or
something like that and give it to her
breakfast dinner two aches twice a day
and then give us a call every couple of
weeks we'll walk you guys through this